hey what's up guys welcome back to Ben
Jiang with babish for this week we're
taking a look at Krabby Patties now
we've already exhausted week when two
Krabby Patties and free oh you guys I'm
Maddie
it's Matt it's out there my house hi
we're here for you
we didn't script this part yet are you
ready for the ultimate burger battle for
today's competition I'm facing off
against Maddie Madison to see who can
make a better burger inspired by the
iconic krabby patty
so who deserves to take home the golden
spatula we leave it in the hands of one
person who knows best pop culture food
legend binging with babish
game on all right here we go
so guys that's not how I talk we are
here to explore the krabby patty do you
guys know what the krabby patty is I
mean does anyone know a krabby patty is
no no idea
you haven't seen spongebob uh yeah like
I know of it I've not ever like sat on
the couch ate a bag of chips watch
Spongebob
oh I've definitely watched spongebob
yeah I grew up on SpongeBob I can't take
her up on it krabby patty Krabby Patties
are like the holy grail of fictional
food okay because the big deal with it
is that there's a secret ingredient that
makes it irresistible msg that's what I
said on my show I said yeah I did msg
and then I tried making a sort of
undersea mommy powder right but here's
the thing I'm just some jag off with a
with a camera you guys are real deal
chefs and I wanted to see how a real
chef makes a krabby patty I will see
which one of you can make the better
patty that's tough in the spirit of the
King Neptune cook-off episode the winner
is going to receive this golden spesh oh
my goodness this is solid 28 carats 20
gold and my second spray painting I want
to hear your best spongebob laugh
Maddie you're up first I'm up first okay
I am going to make a almost like I am a
shrimp cake bun me Big Mac bun last a
little bun Matt button bag bun man bun
Mac bun Mac so I'm gonna just blitz the
shrimp lightly and then blitz a little
bit of the fat into it and that will
emulsify into it and then I'm just gonna
form some patties I have to warn you
yeah I'm one of those [ __ ] with the
cilantro Jean oh you it tastes like so
yeah what the [ __ ] is that why would
they wait is that in the know from the
producers I'm not taking any of the
veins out because you know what Babbage
is hates cilantro anyway so why not feed
them a bunch of shrimp [ __ ] I'm gonna
throw like pork fat
so pork fat and shrimp are best friends
work fats good with anyone kosher kosher
no not today
yum yum yummy um okay so okay yeah I'm
just gonna use some cilantro stems as
try v-type fives like if you like really
don't like cilantro I'm really gonna
really pack in as much cilantro yeah
through the whole thinks that when you
eat it you feel disgusted Birds Eye
chilies
cuz this is gonna be a little picante
get on they say picante for sure so oh
mama this is what you want are you gonna
watch Spongebob after this no Wow
we got a loose wrap what's next and the
fridge fridge yep
[Music]
I think the beverages fridges would be
organized when - they are as I'd say
rat-fucked
what gave you the impression that I was
good
clean guy walk is your fingernails are
nice if I can got the ESOP cream on your
face okay here we go bro
see this is a competition show what
happened big [ __ ] a over here gave me
a [ __ ] little [ __ ] shitty night
dirty over there dude so I'm gonna have
two components I'm gonna have like I
care it in the icon kind of like a loose
marinated kind of thing and then I'm
gonna do a dry kind of slaw with the
napa herb and the onion so we're gonna
balance the fish sauce with the vinegar
a little bit of simple syrup this is
less useless lime zest this this is
looking really good yeah baby I'm gonna
eat this out us out well you know I
didn't want to first show up here and
look like an a-hole
and that's not gonna look like an a-hole
when it's my turn it was like making a
straight up burger a cheeseburger my
entire staff prepped my food I yeah I'm
literally doing everything from scratch
this is no TV [ __ ] magic he's gonna
come over here have a bunch of balls be
like and then you take the stuffs me and
big dog flew in on a [ __ ] goddamn
polar bear off the northern [ __ ] pike
whoo dude does this look nice on camera
I bet it does so you save me the bigger
bowl yeah skip little salad bowls I
think you order so right here I have
onion napa cabbage jalapeno cilantro
stem and some Thai basil and now this is
gonna be the dry component that's gonna
sit on the bottom of the bun and so fill
this bro everything lies right now right
here this Babich gonna like my crabby
burger I don't know Canada USA the
Olympics of the crabby Shaq II burger
thing whatever it is right now right
here sir just gonna make a little patty
and we're gonna get them nice and golden
brown then we're gonna flip and then
we're gonna put the cheese on we're
gonna let those melt and American cheese
oh we're just [ __ ] killing the game
right now oh oh dude that looks so good
yeah it's gonna be a good burger
it smells [ __ ] fantastic amazing cubes
voice in and this is gonna be crazy
flavortown dude here's the big reveal Oh
daddy the man but crunch was right where
it needs to be how's the cilantro I
don't think I can taste it there's not
bother me I think it's more of a
sandwich than a burger oh do you I think
it's strip it's not burger burger that's
a trap take it up with moats much okay
take it up with moats I think that was a
burger George hey hey George I got a
question for you sure what is a
hamburger but a shrimp burger still
burger I'm trying to ponder and say I
just made this like shrimp patty burger
thing but you're saying it's just a
patty burger Alvin you're up all right
we ready for us yeah I'm doing a burger
which is made out of beef
but we established this is a krabby
patty
I pulled inspiration from lots of things
derived from the ocean so I have a wok
on a salad here
I made a dashi brown butter so I made a
dashi stock I made brown butter I threw
the brown butter in the dashi stock
which stood around put in the
refrigerator and all the butter rose to
the top and I harvested that and that's
what I mean you kept the burger in and
then this is senado AoE so it's
basically oval olive oil poached tuna
yeah and I use the olive oil that I used
to push the tuna and I made a male out
of it right and there's actually chunks
of tuna in that so okay this I made
let's say first impressions I like that
you're using undersea stuff yes so much
shots of Chicago mercs cheddar I mean
that just tastes like cheese with it's
good spray cheese yeah it's like cheese
with that's my [ __ ] doctor that's my
that's my plate and cheese is good so
this is what I call mommy dust it's
basically it kombu and then porcini
powder and then salt so yeah this isn't
our special blunt you're smashing for me
today this is the shot that's the shot
she's abuse she's a beauty perfect
goddamn that's what we'll do like a good
chef does is lower than heat use a
[ __ ] thermometer musically he's gonna
lose ten points B's usual bun that we
use at the restaurant that comes back
you okay well that was pretty stale yeah
it will let's go Mayo
senado Mayo mmm what commies salad all
right we'll do some of this Merc shutter
that's my krabby patty all right this I
need to try that cheese mmm little rip
burger good that's really rich let's all
a burger yeah I got a tough decision
maker yeah that's a tough decision first
category richness second category how
much shrimp did it have first category
did it use any undersea ingredients both
eeeh nailed that one second thing I was
looking for was does it have a secret
ingredient and yours had a secret
ingredient did you what would you say
you the secret ingredient of yours was
fish sauce I'll take it
two secret ingredients those were the
things that I was really keeping in mind
but also I mean has it tasted okay both
of these tasted off the charts okay for
flavor alone Maddie I'm gonna give it to
you figures there's 70,000 ingredients
in this that he all prepared himself
who was it a guy lifted his leg got a
secret ingredient a friend you got
yourself a golden spatula I just like to
thank my parents Steve and Joan without
them I wouldn't be here and I just God
God if you're out there up in the clouds
on the big chair with the pearls at the
gates man god you're number one and I
just like to think that the world is
flat and and it's just easier to kind of
see your your future which makes it
really easy for me to just keep being so
successful like winning this sticky
golden spatula so god Earth's flat and
my mom and dad thank you so much world
peace Babbage is my new best friend
Alvin you're still my best friend yeah
we're just a bunch of fellas having a
good time love and West oh just a dash
and there's a big deal with Babbage you
already know cuz the entire world
follows them cookbook coming out October
22nd painters with babish calm / co
clerk
[Music]
and I'm watching it I'm like oh I
noticed lately you need to do this is my
show what's up everybody it's avocado
out of the burger show make sure you
turn on your notifications smash that
like button smash that subscribe button
and thank you for watching